all right Rachel is in White Plains New
York hey Rachel what's up hi Dave thank
you for taking my call
sure how can I help well I just
graduated last December with around
$30,000 in debt and since graduation
I've been my mom's full-time caregiver
she had stage 4 lung cancer oh I'm sorry
thank you um well she passed away last
month and I'm calling because I've
inherited around $50,000 and that's just
from her bank I'll be getting like 33%
because of my siblings over 401k and the
sales are home on top of that I'm just
kind of itching to pay off my student
loans because it would cover that and
then some just to get myself off a clean
slate since I have no other big debts
but right now I'm unemployed because of
the whole situation so just wondering
what your opinion is what should I get
should I go for it and pay off my loan
how much student loan debt that you have
uh roughly 38,000 okay so that way if
you did that that would leave you
$12,000 no the whole 50 thousand is
yours yes and that doesn't have to be
split with your siblings no I calculated
that afterwards I mean so that there was
a hundred and fifty yeah oh okay all
right now
was there a will yes okay and who is
who's the executor of the estate I will
be okay and have you met with the
attorney on the will um yes I just
started to get that settled I'm the
youngest of my siblings and everything's
kind of been thrown on me okay that's
all right you can handle it I think that
I think you sit down with the attorney
the thing is I want the court's
permission or the attorney to give you
that it's okay under New York law for
you to start dispersing this just
because you have access to bank account
doesn't mean you have full rights to
just start divvying it out okay okay I
would have
I was the sole beneficiary of the money
with her bank accounts and under New
York it's separate from the will okay
but you're supposed to disperse the
other you're supposed to disperse some
of that to your siblings that was under
her word and I'm you so the whole bank
account is like 155 so you've got you've
got a problem now yeah
because now you are the owner of
$150,000 you can't just give away
$50,000 yeah without taxes being paid
without you being pummeled with gift tax
so we've got to stop and back up a
little bit now what is this other
properties and everything worth well we
have her house which ünzile oh and
everything it's estimated to be like
three hundred fifty thousand but there's
open building permits from when my dad
took them out and like 92 and the work
has never been done so we would probably
have to sell the house for cash for
around a hundred and fifty is what the
Realtors estimating we'll get okay and
what was the other thing you had to sell
um nothing to sell it's just her 401k oh
okay how much is in it over two hundred
thousand okay good so you're going to
keep a hundred and fifty out of the bank
account and you're going to reduce what
you receive out of the other two things
by one hundred thousand okay because
that's going to keep you from getting
gift taxed mm-hmm you see the difference
okay you're you're now the owner of one
fifty if you give 50 to your sister
you're a gift tax on that you can't you
can't do that
all right you don't get the mess so you
need to get a good tax a person in to
help you with this and now I think I've
just changed this where you're sitting
on 150 K and yes I would pay off my
student loans in that case assuming the
attorney says that what I'm laying out
here is correct and I want you to make
sure you got good legal and good tax
advice around this before you start
dispersing these funds and that you do
it properly it sounds like you are but
double check okay
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show you can
do this you know that really is a
message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or twenty seven thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or five hundred thousand dollar
income